good evening I'm Alexander Rose the
executive director at the long now
foundation and thank you for finding us
in our new venue here at the Marines
memorial tonight's long short and if for
those of you who don't know a long short
is a short film that exemplifies long
term thinking we have consciously been
avoiding doing more time lapses because
they're the easy way out but this one
this one was brought to my attention by
Austin on our staff and it was too
beautiful to pass up and it it shows the
lighting effect in the atmosphere that I
had hoped to see when I was in Svalbard
but it was it's by an eight bolt and
enjoy it please roll the long short
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
I'm Stuart brand from the long now
foundation historians have two major
taboos he can't really be part of the
discipline one is you must never ever
have a theory of history the last time
that was approached in a big way we had
Marx and the Communist Manifesto and a
lot of people killed and so theories of
history that are wrong are lethal and
many historians just decided it's way
too complex it's way too dangerous and
we don't do theories of history so I'll
forget about it you grad students the
other thing the historians are forbidden
to do is talk about the future because
history and the historians discipline is
based on facts and the problem of the
future is it doesn't have any facts yet
therefore to hold forth about fifth
Street the future is obviously just so
much smoke
our speaker tonight perhaps because he
works as an archeologist and
archaeologists are very gritty and what
they do and they have a lot of fun and
what they do and that grit and that fun
and that long perspective is what Ian
Morris brings we please welcome him well
thank you very much it's great to be
here this evening I'd like to thank
Stewart for inviting me to come and
speak to you and I'm Danielle for
organizing me so they actually got here
in time to give the talk and it's great
to see so many of you here tonight the
last time I did a big lecture thing in
the US as a couple of months ago I flew
to Chicago and I flew in the day after
they'd had like the third biggest
snowstorm on record they'd had like
three feet of snow dumped on the city
and they did by the time I landed there
they plowed every street in the city the
plane landed dead on time and there are
no delays anywhere at all so when I woke
up this morning and saw that it was
raining outside I thought you know
clearly there's nothing to worry about
everything's going to be fine and people
did did rain up here as well I left down
the Santa Cruz Mountains it always rains
down there um but so yes I'm glad
everybody was able to come along here
this this evening to hear the talk um my
effect on the weather is actually the
least are barely the beginning of my
superpowers when it comes to giving
talks um a year or so ago I had the
wonderful invitation got to Athens and
give a talk and while I was in Athens
the government there confessed they've
been cooking the books of the previous
five years the country was broke and
they were gonna need an enormous bailout
from the European Union shortly before
that I'd been in Dubai when Dubai World
announced it couldn't pay any of its
bills and so I've decided I'm actually
gonna retire from the professor business
and start just betting against the
currencies of every country I go to and
everything will be fine but so far this
is not yet panned out I haven't become
wealthy yet so I'm actually here this
evening and I'm going to talk a little
bit about what I do and I'm going to
talk particularly about some ideas I
developed while I was writing a book
recently which came out um last autumn
called why the West rules for now
patterns of history and what they reveal
about the future
now um like Stuart was just saying by
background I'm a historian the sort of
people who normally write books like
this tend to be political pundits of
various kinds I'm not really one of
those people I'm a I'm a historian or
I'm at least I'm a part-time historian
I'm the rest of my time I spend being an
archaeologist and I'm a big fan of one
of the sayings of another and somewhat
more famous part-time historian Winston
Churchill who as many of you all know
wrote a wonderful life of mall Dru who
had been one of his relatives many many
historical books um that one of
Churchill's favorite sayings was the
farther backward you can look the
farther forward you're likely to see and
I've always thought this was absolutely
right this is something historian should
be doing now Winston Churchill as a
part-time historian when he wasn't being
historian his day job was saving
civilization my day job when I'm not
being a historian is being an
archaeologist which is different from
and I like to think superior to saving
the world
um what it allows you to do if you're an
archaeologist it allows you to see a lot
further back than most historians do and
I think that's very important for
grasping what the larger shape of
history has been and where it's likely
to go next so in this book that I wrote
I asked the question can we identify the
historical forces that have shaped
Western domination of the world and if
we can can we then project these
enforces forward and see where things
are likely to go next
and I think the answer to both these
questions is yes so okay having said
that there are lots and lots of theories
out there as I'm sure you're aware lots
of theories about why the West rules why
the West came to dominate the planet
I think these theories can be basically
broken down into two broad camps and
what I like to call the long-term
lock-in theories and the short term
accident theories so just want to say a
couple of words quickly about and what
these theories look like there's lots
and lots of different versions of each
kind of theory but and within the first
bundle the long term lock-in theories
the most popular is a kind of classical
theory and then what I mean by that is
it's an idea that goes back to the 18th
centuries when Europeans first start to
dream up this idea and and it's a
classical theory because it goes back to
ancient Greece and the idea is that back
in ancient Greece two-and-a-half
thousand years ago the Greeks come up
with a unique civilization there's
nothing else like it anywhere else in
the world
the Greeks then passed the civilization
on and it's it's picked up by the Romans
and the Romans spread it around over a
much larger area eventually this
civilization gets passed down to the
pinnacle of Western civilization and
here you see the pinnacle of Western
civilization this is the town I was born
in I found this photo in a book it was
the town I was born in taken in the
month I was born and I'm pretty sure
it's a little bit hard to figure out
through the smog what exactly you're
looking at here apart from urban blight
obviously but and pretty sure and if
it's my pointer yeah my point is working
I was born perhaps as this picture was
being taken just about half a mile or so
off in this direction to the left
pinnacle of civilization
but of course I just here is the proper
pinnacle of civilization so this theory
that it runs ancient Greeks invent a
unique civilization passed down unto the
modern West this civilization makes the
West different from and superior to all
other civilizations in the world the UM
the implication is Western domination of
the world was locked in in the distant
past hence the name long-term lock in
theories and also I think there's a kind
of an implication with this but because
it's all locked in the distant past it
might be a permanent state this was the
way the world is fated to be now the
second big clump of theories the short
term accident theories these guys look
at the long term luck in theories and
they just say nonsense all of that is
nonsense everything I just said is
ridiculous if you look at ancient Greece
and Rome they say ancient Greek and
Roman civilizations really not that
different from the ancient Maori an
empire in India or Han Dynasty China or
the mire and Mesoamerica all pre-modern
agrarian civilizations are basically the
same thing the short term accident
theorists will say they say the West
only really pulled ahead of the rest
very recently hence short term theories
and the reason they did so was largely
accidental under the short term accident
theorists disagree among themselves over
what exactly the accident was but they
all agree something kind of accidental
happens set off the Industrial
Revolution in the West my hometown once
again my home town you will be pleased
to learn the first town in the world to
have a clean air act and you can
probably see why so okay the short term
accident theories then say Western
domination is just dumb luck something
happens quite recently tip the West into
an industrial revolution and the rest is
history well okay there are heated
arguments between the proponents of
these theories because both of them as
I'm sure you can see very easily both of
these are theories that can become very
politicized very very quickly heated
arguments have been going on for a long
time now and the thing with these
arguments and they remind me very much
of the famous South Asian story about
the five blind man
and the elephants which I'm sure many of
you know already the story is for that
for reasons which are left obscure in
this story there are five blind guys who
encounter an elephant and they're trying
to figure out what it is and one grabs
the tusks can says oh this is a spear
and somebody else grabs the tail and
says it's a rope and somebody else grabs
a leg and says it's a tree trunk and
they all grab different bits of elephant
anatomy and we probably should not
pursue the story too far really but they
all grab different bits of the anatomy
and say it's something different and the
moral of course is that you if you're
gonna debate about what something is you
must all be talking about the same thing
otherwise the whole discussion will
become pointless very quickly and this I
think has been the case with these
debates about explaining Western
domination of the world people have been
talking about different things using the
same terminology to mean different
things or different terminology to talk
about the same thing different methods
really very much talking past each other
so when I started getting interested in
this question it seemed to me that the
first thing to do was to figure out what
the arguments are really about when
people are having these big disputes and
it seemed to me the the core thing here
in these debates was one in my book I
came to call Social Development this is
what the arguments about Social
Development and by Social Development I
basically means society's abilities to
get things done
now I'm one of my pet hates I have a lot
of pet hates but one of them is people
who read PowerPoint slides out but I am
now about to do this you know basically
because I can I got the projector and
this fancy little microphone here so I'm
gonna read the PowerPoint thing out to
you because I obviously I need to say a
little bit more than just society's
ability to get things done of what I
mean by social development so the way I
define this is a bundle of technological
subsistence organizational and cultural
accomplishments through which people
feed clothe house and reproduce
themselves explain the world around them
resolve disputes within their
communities extend their power at the
expense of other communities and defend
themselves against others attempts to
their power that's basically what I mean
I'm really what it is is a groups
ability to master its physical and
intellectual environments and in
principle at least I think this is
something that we ought to be able to
measure and then compare across time and
space
now I also think the long term lock-in
theories it seems to me those are
basically saying that West and Social
Development has been ahead of
development in the rest of the world for
a very long time map since ancient Greek
times short-term accidents say no it has
it's just not like that at all
and these I think are basically
quantitative claims about how much
Social Development two different parts
of the world have at different points in
time and that I think is a solution to
the elephant problem if we can agree
that this is what we're talking about
then we ought to be able to measure it
and argue about it a bit more precisely
now I'm not trying to claim that
numerical comparisons of Social
development's are more objective than
other ways of looking at this problem
having spent a long time I'm working on
this are you've acutely aware of all the
assumptions and guesses and hunches are
going to doing this so I don't think
that measuring social development makes
you more objective but it does make you
more explicit it forces you to say I'm
gonna look at this and this and this and
not that enough of that and I'm gonna
measure them in these ways and these are
the numbers I come up with and this is
why I came up with these numbers and if
someone then disagrees with you they can
attack you on the basis of what you've
actually done rather than starting from
totally different set of premises so
this seemed to me like a good thing to
do so I spent a long time calculating
Social Development scores but different
parts of the world across the 15
thousand years since the end of the last
major Ice Age asking myself basically
one question over and over again do long
term luck in theories or short term
accident theories correspond better to
reality now I could bore you rigid with
an account of my Social Development
Index and I say this with confidence
because I've done it several times now
so audience is it really knock some just
dead in there see
but I won't do that because I'm up on
the screen there is a URL where if you
are the kind of obsessive person I am
you can go there and download an entire
book that is about nothing except my
Social Development Index and I strongly
recommend that no one I've met even my
bitterest enemies have no one has yet
admitted to reading the whole thing the
whole way through so this is a good sign
I think so but I just like one very
quick thing about the index before
moving on to I'll talk about results and
when I was trying to figure out you know
how do you do this this thing the
ability of societies to master their
physical intellectual environment how do
you actually measure that and I ended up
taking inspiration from something the
United Nations did about 20 years ago
and they dreamed up what they call the
Human Development Index and the idea
with that is they've got all these
organizations are looking for ways to
invest to to raise welfare in different
parts of the world so some of the
economists said what we need is a simple
index it will help you with your
investment decisions so they decided
what we want is a way to measure human
development by which they meant the
ability of governments to create
conditions to allow their citizens to
realize their human potential and so
they said we want some way to measure
this and we could try to just mini
measure everything is because everything
is relevant here but we don't want to do
that because it's stupid and pointless
what we want is the smallest possible
number of traits with roughly cover what
we mean by human development and which
can be measured and they came up with
three traits and they looked if I can
get them straight they they looked at
life expectancy at Birth real wages and
levels of education in different
countries calculated this score now that
seemed to me to be a really good way to
do this um social development that I'm
looking at it's a bit different so I use
different traits to look at and what I
did was come up with four traits which
were per capita energy capture on levels
of organization within the society by a
wet wave for which I used a proxy
measure and I just looked at the size of
the largest settlement within a society
um the forms of information technology
and then last but sadly not least a more
making capacity which now has to be part
of the index
this so that's what I did that was my
idea for doing this index and okay yeah
so while moving along I mean that is
enough preamble about my index you might
think that is it too much preamble
now it's time to look at the results so
big drumroll we now have a graph which
shows you the shape of human history and
there it is yet now I don't understand
why do people always laugh at my graph
this rules me but yes I mean I do
actually sort of see the humor in my
graph after all this time working on it
this is what I come up with and it's
sort of oh oh that's it
so yeah the obvious thing here is you
look at this graph and unless your
eyesight is way better than mine which
it may well be at this stage in my life
it's sort of hard to see very much going
on here so initially I was a bit
disappointed with my graph but I think
there are actually several interesting
things going on here quite important
things I would say first thing I should
say about my graph I've just got two
lines on the graph out of all the
different regions in the world I looked
at this graph just shows you a western
region and an eastern region and what I
mean by those and why there's only two
of them I'll come back to that in just a
second but um the first thing you see
when you look at this graph first thing
that struck me was how similar the lines
are which I think if you're a long term
lock-in theorist that's kind of bad news
though the lines are so similar
second thing you see the lines he's my
pointer again the lines kind of putter
along the bottom of the graph put up on
a putter not much is going on about 2000
BC they sort of dragged themselves off
the bottom it wobbles around a little
bit but still you know really not a lot
is going on here and then you get to
about the Year 1800 they take a 90
degree turn to the left and shoot off
the top of the page almost now this
again this sounds like good news for the
short term accident theory so say that
basically nothing really happens then a
couple hundred years ago everything
happens so two observations about that
graph the problem though I think is that
the second of my observations largely
explains the first and what I mean by
that in order to get the score the
where's the point again though the
Western score for the year two thousand
nine hundred and six points up here in
order to get that score on this
because I've got to have the graph go up
to a thousand which means squishing down
all of the earliest scores down into a
very very small area now I should have
said that here we got the dates from
14,000 BC up to the year 2000 they
stopped in 2000 there's a nice round
number
here the Social development's score from
0 which is actually it's not possible to
score 0 would mean we were capturing no
energy from the environment which would
mean we'd all be dead so 0 you can't
actually do 0 but up to a thousand which
is the biggest number of points you
could theoretically score for the year
2000 in order to go up to a thousand on
this graph you got to squish everything
else down so the next picture I'm going
to show you is this exactly the same
data but leaving off the really high
scores for the year 2000 so the next
graph just goes up to the year 1900 now
what we look at this graph clearly this
is a rather different sort of graph
there's a lot more going on than we
could see in the first graph and the
previous graph go back to the second
again it looks like the eastern and
western scores the red and the blue
scores they're more or less the same
until very recently in this graph we see
that's actually not the case the western
score has been higher than the East and
for 90% of the time since the last ice
age which you might say ah long term
luck in theory this is now good news for
the long term guys second thing I think
we see on this graph that um previous
graph it looks like the lines are
basically flat almost all the time
dragged up a little bit and then there's
this huge change in in recent times this
graph we see that's actually not the
case the scores have been rising
generally since the end of the Ice Age
slowly and then accelerating certainly
but the scores have been rising almost
all the time next thing we see though
scores don't rise consistently they rise
as periods of fast rising there's
periods of stagnation as periods of
collapse and decline in the Social
development's scores this is something
we just couldn't see on the previous
graph last thing I would say we see on
this graph the western score the blue
line is not ahead all of the times ahead
90% of the time but not all the time
there's a twelve hundred year period
roughly the
50 around here to their 1750 over here
where the eastern score is higher than
the Western that's very bad news for the
long-term lock in theory because that
really shouldn't happen if things were
locked in a very long time ago now I
think to explain all the the six
observations I just made about the two
graphs to explain all of those you you
have to explain all of those I think if
you're going to answer the question
about why the West rules you can't get
away with just explaining one or two of
them and I think in fact this calls um
thought like Stuart mentioned for some
kind of general theory of history there
can take all of the near the teeming
details of the real history and reduce
them to a few underlying principles so
that's what I can try to develop in my
book and I came to the conclusion that
we need three intellectual tools to
understand to explain why the West rules
for now the first of these tools I think
is biology biology ought to be
fundamental to everything humans do
because it when it's not and often it
isn't and when it's not it means we
don't understand what we are biology
tells us what we are we are animals it
tells us that people are all pretty much
the same wherever you find them all over
the world throughout their history
humans have all been pretty much the
same and the thing that we are the same
thing that we all are all around the
world is clever chimpanzees we do more
or less what chimpanzees do but we do it
better we have the 2.7 pounds of magic
up in the top of our heads these brains
that are so far beyond the brain suppose
we know of any other living thing we can
do what chimpanzees do but we do it
better
so chimpanzees are able to munch down on
their bananas catch the odd monkey and
smash its brain out and eat it whereas
human beings um my students at Stanford
just come back from Spring Break on
spring break they can go to the
Caribbean and drink beer on the beach
until they pass out which I'm certain
chimpanzees would do if they could but
they can't so this is what we are the
first thing we need to know is about
biology which tells us what we are
second thing we need to know is about
sociology by which I that's it's a
shorthand expression for the social
sciences writ large um
biology tells us about how individual
human animals behave what they get up to
the sociology tells us about how
societies as large groups behave how
societies deal with change what causes
change in societies and what the changes
caused in the societies I think you've
got to have both of these things once
you put the two together I think you've
got a universalizing kind of bio social
theory about humanity applies to all
people in all times and places
I think biology and sociology tell us
why social development generally
increases across time why it's sometimes
stagnates and falls but these two things
don't tell us about east/west
differences why the Western score is
higher than the Eastern why why it's
been higher for so much of our history
and I think to explain that we need the
third tool and the third tool is
geography its geography I suggest in my
book that tells us why groups of people
which people are all pretty much the
same and why groups of these people are
all the same which and these groups kind
of develop along similar lines because
the societies are basically all pretty
much the same and yet the groups fare
differently in different places and this
I suggest is because the places are
different the people are the same the
society the social groups are the same
but the place is a difference now this
is a very simple claim to make but it
has big consequences big implications it
means that the Western domination of the
world is not explained by great men or
great women it's not explained by
culture it's not explained by religion
it's not explained by politics its
geography that explains why the West
rules and also geography that explains
why Western rule is coming to an end so
okay I could actually stop right there
where you'll all be done and the problem
of course is some obvious questions then
arise if things are really so simple why
is history so messy and I'm sure you all
studied history in high school college
you
you know history is messy why is it so
messy also if it's so simple why haven't
people figured this out before if it's
really that simple and actually people
have figured this out before and how did
the first person to suggest that
geography is the big motor but it's
certainly not the way most historians
see things so why is history so messy
why is this not a more popular theory
the answer to both of these questions I
think is the geography itself is messy
that's why the results are messy too and
I realized as I was writing my book that
geography operates as a kind of a
two-way streets on the one hand
geography determines how societies
develop but the way societies developed
term ins what geography means and this
is my my basic shtick in this book um
now to convince you that I'm right in
this obviously what we should do now is
you should all leave and go outside and
buy my book and take it home and read it
very very carefully and then you will be
absolutely convinced that I'm right
about this but since I've got you here
right now um I will try to convince you
of the basic truth of these claims but
to do that we now have to plunge into
some actual history I mean it may have
come to your attention I mean doing all
this talking so far there's been
precious little actual history in this
so what I will now want to do is take us
on a sort of whirlwind tour of the last
fifteen thousand years of Eastern and
Western history trying to demonstrate
the validity of the claim I'm making and
and what that might teach us if it's
true so I want to go back fifteen
thousand years a long time to start off
with to the end of the last ice age and
the reason I'm gonna stop at that point
is that that is the point at which I
think we first begin to see really
distinctive ways of life appearing in
different parts of the world what
happens at the end of the Ice Age as the
war world warms up there's half a dozen
places around the world there's actually
there's a little bit about the debate
among archaeologists over precisely what
the places are but these places come
under a reasonable amount of green
agreement there's half a dozen places
where and we're very new kinds of
society start to emerge at the end of
the Ice Age what's new about these
societies is it in these places not
really anywhere
in these places humans begin to
domesticate plants and animals this
supports much larger populations and the
humans begin to develop much more
complicated societies to live in now why
these places why then well this is
something that I think has become
increasingly clear across the last 20
years and I'm Jared Diamond's book Guns
Germs of steel I'm sure many of you will
have encountered I think is far and away
the clearest and best explanation of why
these places and dimond explains really
lucidly that geography is the reason
domestication begins in these places
you'll notice on this map there all
along a roughly similar band of
latitudes these are the only places in
the world in the world where topography
and climate conspire to allow the
evolution of the kinds of large plants
and heavy grains so heavy grain grants
and large mammals that can be
domesticated and bent to the human will
to produce more food for the humans
these are the places where it can happen
and within these places the place in the
world where it happens fastest and most
easiest is here the area archaeologists
like to call the hilly flax this is
where geography conspires to produce the
densest concentrations of domesticable
plants and animals that's why it happens
there first because it's easiest there
are most of these things it starts there
certainly by the year 9500 BCE across
the next 2,000 years the other places
you see on this map start to have their
own domestication processes after that
data other places join in the process as
well now what this means is the part of
the world that starts producing complex
societies with rising social development
first is this hilly flanks area here and
in in my book what I did was what I
think is a sort of common sense thing to
do is to say that I'm going to refer to
Western societies as the ones who trace
their roots in complex societies back to
the westernmost core area within Eurasia
in the hilly flanks modern Western
societies in one way or another we could
say have all sort of developed out of
this core area here and spread out from
there through migration and diffusion
across the intervening 11
thousand plus years I mean the other end
of Eurasia we have another core area and
I described the societies that the
complex societies had developed out of
that as the Eastern societies the ones
that developed out of the young yellow
Yangtze Valley's area I ended up in my
book doing a comparison of really just
these two these two traditions its
Western and Eastern tradition um largely
to keep the book within a manageable
length I wanted originally to look at
everything but that was gonna hang this
book would be this fad
I probably got very upset with me and so
I trimmed it down to just these two
places because the parts of the world
that I have had the highest social
development scores since the end of the
Ice Age have always been societies that
descended from one of these two cores so
we could kind of simplify the problem by
just doing this two-way comparison which
I think gives us enough information to
answer the questions so anyway whether
that's true or not um
everywhere you get domestication
population grows it expands
geographically through migration and
through people emulating what's going on
in the areas of domestication as it
expands as the societies become more
complex rising social development
changes the meanings of geography
geography drove where the process starts
the process and takes over starts
changing what geography means what I
mean by that um if we look just to this
Helly flanks area again farming spreads
out relatively quickly across Europe
within four thousand years it's gone all
the way to the Atlantic it's gone off
into Central Asia but it moves extremely
slowly come back here moves extremely
slowly the short distance down here into
what we now call Iraq now the reason for
that is geographical um if you live in
Iraq in ancient times and you try to do
what the farmers up in the hilly flanks
to which is take a handful of wheat or
barley planted in the ground and stand
there with your arms out waiting for the
rain to fall you will wait a very long
time the rain is not going to fall um
you can't farm that way in Iraq it just
isn't gonna work our Iraq is a very
marginal backward kind of place in the
early farming system what changes that
around is that
as social development increases you get
more more complex societies people
figure out a new way to do farming
instead of rating waiting for the rains
to fall they wait for the great
Euphrates and Tigris rivers to flood
they figure out if we um combine the
flooding of the rivers with this
brilliant technological breakthrough the
big ditch this is the technical word for
it you see here the big ditch if you dig
a big ditch you can catch as the rivers
flood you can drain the water up into a
big storage pit and then when you need
to water your crops to to fertilize and
get them growing you can take the water
from the big pit another technical term
and put it in your field everything will
grow great now that sounds very simple
it actually there's a lot of
technicalities to it it takes thousands
of years for people to really crack the
system of irrigation farming once they
do though it abruptly changes the
meaning of geography ancient Iraq goes
from being this backwater where farming
is almost impossible to pull off to
suddenly being a place where if you're
doing this kind of stuff you now
generate agricultural yields much much
higher than the Helly flanks could do so
very quickly after about 5,000 BC um
ancient Mesopotamia and ancient Egypt
begin to overtake the hilly flanks as
the core of the western area they're bad
geography has become good geography as
they do that other things happen the new
meaning of geography pushes up social
development further the villages get
bigger and bigger the villages start to
turn into actual cities as that happens
the city dwellers discover oh there's
this whole new advantage the rivers not
only can we irrigate our crops we can
also trade along the rivers which is
much cheaper than moving goods by land
we can move taxes and armies up and down
the rivers the rivers become
indispensable for the cities as the
cities get bigger driven by this use of
the rivers as the cities get bigger new
changes start to set in as the cities
turn into real empires people realize Oh
rivers are great but entire seas those
are even better the Mediterranean Sea
goes from being a kind of backward
fringe a boundary to the
ancient world and to be a kind of super
highway connecting the ancient world and
particularly as the first millennium BCE
goes on we get the emergence of new
great empires like particularly the
Roman Empire based over here at city of
Rome Rome is able to unite the whole
Mediterranean Basin this turns into this
kind of super motor for social
development
geography changes meanings um as it does
so social development is pushed up
higher and higher still now by the end
of the first millennium BCE you've got a
series of Empires of arisen all across
Eurasia from the Roman Empire out at the
left of this map over to the Han Dynasty
Chinese Empire the right string of other
empires in between um the Roman Empire
has the Mediterranean Sea is this in a
highway it's always the biggest and
richest of these empires but all of them
have very powerful empires now as the
empires get bigger you can probably
guess at this point what I'm about to
say as the empires get bigger they
change the meanings of geography further
as social development increases and in
particular what these ancient empires do
it's not changing the meaning of the
geography around their borders in
particular the geography of one on this
map I call the steppe highway running
from Hungary in the West all the way out
to Manchuria in the Far East
this band of very arid flat grasslands
running across Eurasia that um once
you've got domesticated horses and big
domesticated horses really you can move
very very quickly back and forth along
this step highway once you have really
big empires to the south of the steps
there are people you can trade with and
people you can raid as you move back and
forth along the steppe highway so the
rise of the big empires Kanna transforms
what the steps mean you get the
evolution of big nomadic empires on the
steppes as this happens the nomadic
empires interact more and more with the
stable agrarian empires they start to
undermine these agrarian empires in the
early to mid first millennium CE II
certainly by the by the Year 200 CE II
they're starting to cause the empires to
collapse so much movement is going on
the migration to spy
they out of control the empires are
breaking down under pressure in
particular they're the big thing that
happens is people from the different
ends of Eurasia start to merge their
disease pools this is something I now
feel very much an expert on a couple of
weeks ago I went off to give a talk
about the German translation of my book
and I did five different german-speaking
cities in five days personally merging
their disease pools as I traveled by the
fifth day I honestly thought I could
barely stand up anyway I couldn't speak
which was perhaps a mercy but I was so
sick now in the first millennium CE II
the first couple essentially see we see
this on a spectacular scale in Eurasia
horrific new diseases break out a huge
part in undermining the ancient empires
all across Eurasia the big empires
collapse social development plunges for
all kinds of reasons that I won't bore
you with right now western end of
Eurasia never again gets reunited into a
single great Empire the eastern end does
though in 589 China is reunited into a
single great Empire and when that
happens a same old story changes the
meanings of geography once again
reuniting China to single empire in the
6th century allows them to create a kind
of new agricultural frontier in the
south of China based on rice cultivation
huge increase in productivity and and
they're able to go even further than
that lesser thing is one of the really
interesting things in medieval Chinese
history they create a kind of manmade
version of the Mediterranean Sea by
digging the Grand Canal that links the
Fertile rice growing areas of the
Yangtze base and points further south
links it and all the way up to the great
cities of the north the Chinese economy
booms in the seventh eighth ninth
centuries and this in many ways is the
Golden Age of Chinese culture if you
read classical Chinese poetry it will
probably be poetry from the tongue
dynasty of these years the tongue and
the succeeding Song Dynasty this is the
Golden Age of pre-modern Chinese science
all kinds of inventions all kinds of
technological breakthroughs are
happening this is the period when East
and Social Development rises higher than
waist where
and social developments as it does it
once again begins to recreate reconnect
the whole of Eurasia the overlapping
zones of trade and warfare Mongol
migrations black death all kinds of
things happen that people haven't really
been looking for but similar kind of
recreation of these trade zones now all
kinds of stuff is getting invented out
in China in this period but I want to
draw your attention to just two things
that are popping up at a China in the
13th and 14th centuries which pushed
social development upward um but also
change the meaning of geography
spectacularly and this is where the
story really begins to sort of reach its
its climaxes with these inventions in
the 13th and 14th centuries and both of
the inventions spread like wildfire once
they get invented everybody loves them
now the first of the inventions is
practical ocean-going ships there have
been ships before this that could cross
the oceans like Viking longboats but
they're not very reliable and they have
to have very specific circumstances to
do this by the 13th century the Chinese
are building ships that can reliably
sail across thousands and thousands of
miles and in case anybody doubts the
truth of this in 2009 a group of
entrepreneurs on Taiwan built a replica
of an early 15th century Chinese junk
they sailed it all the way from Taiwan
to San Francisco and I don't know if any
of you went down and saw it while it
stayed several months in the San
Francisco Bay befitting so they refitted
it in the San Francisco Bay they turned
it around and the difficult part with
pre-modern ships is actually not getting
from China to California it's getting
back again because of the winds and
tides that's a tricky bit so they turn
around they're gonna prove this can be
done off they go
they sail the whole way back to Taiwan
they get within 20 miles of the coast of
Taiwan and the middle of the night steel
freighter slices the ship into and
that's what you see on the top right now
the good news is nobody died it was all
fine and the bad news is is it's kind of
disappointing that that's how it ended
but you're obviously what the 15th
century know steel freighters and the
problem with doing this now of course is
a replica junk no GPS no so
no you don't see the steel freighters
but yeah the 15th century didn't have
steel freighters so this proves you know
beyond any reasonable doubt that this
this could be done and this these
inventions the the inventions that make
ocean-going ships possible they spread
like wildfire within a century or the
most - they spread all the way to the
backward fringe of Western Eurasia
Northwest Europeans have got these
things now second invention the Chinese
come up with it changes everything
spreads even faster this in fact is the
fastest spreading invention the world
has ever seen up to this point and this
invention is the gun everybody loves
guns on the top left what you see is the
oldest known true gun in the world if in
the year 12 88 found in Manchuria in
northeast China what you see in the
bottom right is an illustration from a
manuscript in Oxford I'm painting them
here 1327 less than 40 years later
showing a much improved version of a gun
so in basically a human lifespan this
thing has spread 4,000 miles overland
from China to Western Europe
everybody loves guns so these two
inventions these set off the most
spectacular transformation of geography
the world had seen up till this point
what I mean by that um let's have a map
here we are Western Europe at this point
to say around the Year 1400 Western
Europe is very disadvantaged by
geography it's a cold wet place it
sticks out into the shores of the North
Atlantic it's a long way from the real
centres of action the centres of action
in the Western world are down here in
the Mediterranean Basin Italy Venice the
Ottoman Empire that's where everything
is going on northwest Europe miserable
place I know this I grew up there
miserable place geography has put it
under the sword disadvantage now having
said that interesting geographical fact
Western Europe is about 3,000 miles in a
straight line from America eastern Asia
is about 6,000 miles the way you would
have to say although catching the winds
and tides about 6,000 miles from North
America twice as far away
now through all of human history up to
about the Year 1400 this has been
completely irrelevant to anything it's a
fact it's true but it just doesn't
matter because if you can't cross the
oceans it doesn't matter which which of
them you can sort cross least it really
is irrelevant to anything once you can
cross the oceans though this abruptly
goes from being a trivial geographical
fact to being the most important fact in
the world it's a bit like what I'm
saying when it's talking about the
origins of Agriculture agriculture
begins in Southwest Asia the hilly
flanks not because Helle flankers are
more energetic or cleverer than anybody
else but because it's easier their
geography has made it easier in the
fifteenth century it's easier for
Europeans to cross to the Americas than
it is for East Asians because it's twice
as close there's also other pressures on
Europeans they know that the real wealth
of the world is in East Asia they've got
these great new ships these guns they
can use to kill the people they meet
when they get to the other end they want
to get to East Asia some of them are so
deluded about the size of the world
Christopher Columbus for example
Columbus is convinced it's only 4,000
miles from Portugal to China he is way
off the mark everybody else knows it's
three times as far they all tell him
this he refuses to believe them he sets
off sailing west to get to the east
bumps into the Americas changes
everything
but even if Columbus had been a bit
cleverer and hadn't discovered the
Americas other people would have done so
very very soon in 1500 another Italian
Salem ganon Cabral is trying to sail to
India and to get to India you have to
swing out way out into the Atlantic
Ocean to pick up the today the winds
that will take you around the bottom of
Africa he swings a little bit too far he
bumps into Brazil once Europeans have
gotten these ships it's inevitable
they're going to discover the Americas
it's easier for Europeans to do this and
for East Asians Europeans go on to be
the first people first and non Americans
to find colonize and plunder the
Americas and start drawing the Americas
into an economic system based on their
own countries they change the meaning of
geography spectacular
what are the precise thing I mean by
that is these new ships they turn the
Atlantic Ocean into a kind of Goldilocks
ocean it's neither too big nor too small
what that means it's big enough that in
different Shores around the Atlantic
while the different things are happening
so up in Europe you've got those sort of
early stages of as a manufacturing
economy is being developed
daran Africa you've got totally
different sorts of societies where
people can capture slaves Europeans and
capture slaves over in the Americas
you're growing completely different
sorts of crops sugar and tobacco
flourish cotton flourishes the Europeans
turn the North Atlantic into this famous
triangular economy that you've probably
heard about in high school where you can
sail around the economy from Europe down
to Africa over to the Americas back
again I'm picking up different Goods
different points selling at each point
along your trade making profits
everywhere you go generating enormous
revenues now that's only the beginning
of what happens when the job if he
changes meaning Europeans realize boy
this is this is great we're getting so
rich if we really understood how the
winds and the tides work and how the
stars move though we could get so much
richer and Europeans start thinking
about these problems much harder than
before they start developing entirely
new ways to look at nature in order to
answer these questions about how the
winds and the tides work how the stars
move they've got to come up with
entirely new kinds of mathematics they
promptly do so Newton and Leibnitz at
the end of the 17th century both of them
invent calculus which you need to solve
these problems both of them then spend
the rest of their lives accusing the
other of stealing the idea from them but
a cascade of breakthroughs follows in
mathematics physics chemistry biology
Europe has a 17th century Scientific
Revolution China doesn't India doesn't
the Turkish Empire doesn't not because
Europeans are smart on these other
people but because they're asking
different questions geography has
changed its meaning forcing new
questions upon the European
as their natural scientific
understanding of the world takes off in
the 18th century they start applying
these sorts of methods back onto their
own society in what we normally call the
Enlightenment asking how does society
work can we have a political science
which can explain our society by the end
of the 18th century profits are being
driven up so high by the Atlantic
economy particularly in Britain which is
coming gradually to dominate the
Atlantic economy profits are being
driven up so high then wages are being
driven up as well and British
entrepreneurs are finding that they're
being priced out of their export markets
in Europe they can't produce the goods
as cheaply as other people because the
wages are being driven up so high what
they need they realize is some way to
substitute machinery for labour so they
start trying to mechanize production
they go even further they start tapping
into the energy of fossil fuels to drive
their machines as they do this Britain
has an industrial revolution and again
not because the Brits are smarter or
work harder than other people but
because they're asking different
questions different questions are thrust
on them by geography coal and steam
allow the British to project their power
globally they conquer India they crush
China by 1860 they bestride the world
like a colossus now all of this has
happened basically because of the way
geography has changed its meanings since
the Year 1400 and that's why I say it's
geography that explains why the West
rules so ok that's almost enough history
for now when I was in high school back
in the dark days of the 1970s when I was
in high school that actually really was
enough history for now it's something
that didn't really strike me at the time
but all of our modern history textbooks
and British high schools ended in the
year 1870 history came to a full stop as
we said in Britain remarkable
coincidence just a I'm sure there was no
sinister motive of course but just at
the point that Britain destroyed the
world like a colossus history came to an
end now the problem of course is you can
end your textbook
in 1870 but the British could not
actually stop history in 1870 the same
mechanisms kept on working after 1870
the mechanisms that can turn the
Atlantic into a Goldilocks ocean carry
on working in the late 19th century you
get steam ships you get railroads
drawing the economies of Central Europe
for the Germans in particular and North
America the u.s. in particular drawing
these into this British dominated world
economy as this happens same old story
once again people in Germany in the u.s.
they find they can't run an industrial
capitalist economy in quite the same
ways as the British because they don't
live in Britain it's a different country
they have to tinker with it to make it
work as they tinker with it they
discover oh we are making it work better
than the British to the British like to
laugh at the Germans in America say they
can't do anything properly by 1900 they
discover the Germans and Americans are
doing it better than the British and
this is a graphing a slightly
bewildering mass of coloured lines here
but it's showing you per capita levels
of industrialization from 1750 to 1913
and the big thing that we see in this
graph of course is first of all the
British take off down here leaping ahead
of the rest of the world and then
accelerating for about 1860 onward the
German and particularly the American
catch up by the year 1900 the US has
displaced Great Britain as the core of
the Western economy that dominates the
world now I did not study history in an
American high school but I've been
reliably assured my friends who did the
us modern history textbooks all stopped
around the Year 1970 remarkable
coincidence the American problem once
again is that geography still refused to
stop working in 1970 when the US
dominated the whatever strode the world
like a colossus same processes keep
working the sort of processes that made
the Atlantic a Goldilocks ocean then
basically shrunk it into a pond in the
late 20th century these shrink the
Pacific into a pond this of course is
one of the reasons a San Francisco
becomes a great global
city but what it also does is draws East
Asia into this global economy East
Asians like uh North Americans are
discovered in the late 19th century the
late 20th century East Asians discover
ways to to rejigger Western capitalism
and industrialism to make them work back
in East Asia East Asia starts bounding
up after the Western core and catching
up
East Asian cities becomes remarkable as
Western cities and this at the topic was
the famous bird's nest in Beijing built
for the Olympics and down at the bottom
right is the architect I Weiwei who as
I'm sure you know got arrested a week or
two ago and Chinese have learned that
you can build cities that are even more
spectacular than Western cities but if
you want to do that you must have
architects and if you are going to have
architects you have to learn to put up
with them being annoying this is what
architects and artists do there are
annoying people I I for a while I was a
Dean at Stanford responsible the
humanities department I learned this
firsthand artists very annoying people
so if you're going to do this you you
have to put up with annoying people I'm
afraid but the bottom line here this is
an inexorable process driven by
geography something that people can't
really control this process so okay that
is why the West rules for now that is
the title of my book to wrap up though I
want to spend in the last few minutes
turning to the subtitle of the book the
patterns of history and what they reveal
about the future now I suggest in my
book that there's two real lessons so we
can draw from history and learn from
history for thinking about the future
the first of these lessons is that we
can identify the big trends the big
forces that have driven global history
second thing we can do is identify the
the countervailing forces that might
derail these trends because the trends
don't just play out in a simple linear
or even logarithmic kind of way they get
derailed this side these I think are the
two big things we can learn from history
the forces that drive it and what
derails it now taking the first of these
lessons the forces that drive history
if we take um the 20th century rates of
increase in Social development's in the
eastern and western cause and simply
project them forward so you know take
what I calculated from 1900 to 2000
project them forward for 2000 to 2100 we
get a new graph this is the graph we get
red line is the East again the blue line
is the West what you see here is the red
line the eastern line will catch up with
the Western line in the year 21:03 so
make a note of that put that in your
diary that is the point at which Western
rule will end now I've always been told
it's a very good idea if you're going to
predict things be as precise as possible
so I've been very precise for you the
other thing I've always been told to do
is predict things which will not come
true Awful's within your own lifetime
very very important on Monday I mean we
had a little debate down at Stanford our
between though there's me and one of my
colleagues from the political science
department and Frank Fukuyama who's just
published his new book about actually
about Eastern Western history and
professor Fukuyama is best known for
this book he wrote a bunch in the early
nineties the end of history predicting
the width the fall of the Soviet Union
history had basically reached its
endpoints and the societies had
developed as far as they were going to
go now everybody was going to be liberal
capitalists now his great mistake as I
and his other critics like to point out
is to make a prediction where you'll
know within 15 years whether you were
right or not mine who can tell so okay
in Easton the the implication of the
trends of history is that the east will
catch up with the West acting not in the
Year 2103 that's obvious is silly to try
to be that precise but by the end of the
21st century we will see the East
catching up that's one thing that this
graph shows you here we are crossing
over here which comes to more about this
point here 2103 what the graph also
shows us so the point where these lines
cross going along now this way it's the
vertical axis um the point is round
about five
and points on my social development
scale now what does that mean
well in the 15,000 years since the end
of the last ice age um social
development in the West has risen by
about 900 points 900 points takes you
from cave paintings at Alta Mira to the
long now foundation the implication of a
steady states change across the 21st
century is that there will be four times
as much change in the 21st century as
we've seen in the entire time since the
end of the Ice Age now that is a fairly
mind-boggling sort of prognosis to make
now all kinds of people speculated on on
what a world at five thousand points
might look like many many predictions
have been made and most of them I'm sure
when you look at predictions that were
made in the past about what the future
would be like they're always comically
wrong and I'm sure the predictions have
been made now many of them right here in
the Bay Area will also turn out to be
comically wrong but having said that um
they do give us a sense I think of what
the world might come to look like if we
do see the great trends just continuing
out into the future without a change and
this graph here this is a graph drawn
and by the futurist Ray Kurzweil who
again I'm sure many of you know cause
whales were probably a lot better than I
do what this graph is showing us is the
the power of supercomputers since the
year 1990 um graphed on a logarithmic
scale here so each unit you go up the
vertical axis of you're actually going
ten times as far in straightforward
linear measurements as you would on a
normal kind of scale and what Kurzweil
was trying to show is just how strong
and consistent this trend has been out
here up to his book was published in the
year 2005 so out as far as the range of
them planned for supercomputers Kurzweil
pointed out but if this trend were to
continue by the year 2030 so very close
to now we will have brain scanning so
precise that we can generate neuron by
neuron level scans of your brain
your actual brain can be scanned into a
computer with all of your individual
memories everything will be in there
because after all the year the way your
brain works is electrical signals flash
back and forth between the neurons in
your brain so we'll scan an exact
replica of your brain by the year 2030
by the year 2025 up here we'll have
supercomputer so powerful that they can
actually run this simulation of your
brain
Kurzweil suggests or what that means is
that that program running on that
computer will be another you now a lot
of people say no it's not there's a lot
of reasons why you maybe that's a silly
thing to say but the implication of the
trends are though by the year 2025
there'll be computers so powerful they
can mimic the actions of an individual
human by the year 2045
if the trends continue growing
exponentially we will have computing
power so great that all of the thought
processes of all of the seven billion
people living on earth can be uploaded
to mainframes what Kurzweil predicts
from this he says at that point we will
have reached what he likes to call the
singularity the point at which change
becomes so fast
it's basically instantaneous all of the
intelligence of all of the beings on
earth will be merged into one super
intelligence one machine based life form
that is greater trillions of times
greater than the sum of all the
biological intelligence on earth now if
that happens I think Frank Fukuyama's
end of history actually will be upon us
the sort of forces I've been talking
about biology sociology geography they
will surely cease to mean anything at
all in a world that looks even vaguely
like that so that's one second lesson
that we learn is that forces do derail
these trends um if you look back through
history there have been these great
social collapses and the slightly
alarming thing is if you look at the
really big social collapses in the past
the forces that drove them and tend to
be rather similar to forces that many
observers worried about in the world
right now
uncontrollable large-scale migration is
one of these forces the breakdown of
major states complete collapse of states
another one in the force is linked of
course very often to the migrations the
spread of epidemic diseases in new forms
again often linked to the migrations um
massive famine as people start to outrun
the food supply exacerbated by disease
migration at state failure and then the
fifth of the forces which is always in
the mix somewhere is rapid climate
change in a way that people can't
control and obviously you don't need me
to tell you that these are big worries
in the 21st century world so one
prediction we might make is that the
21st century might and should be heading
toward the sort of collapse we saw with
the end of the Roman Empire now I
actually think that's highly unlikely
for one very good reason and and the
reason is this we now have the ability
to annihilate ourselves completely this
is the biggest nuclear explosion ever
I'm a 58 Megaton bomb that the Soviets
set up in 1961 if we now have a massive
international global scale social
collapse and I think it's highly
unlikely to play out like the fall of
the Roman Empire I think it's much more
likely we're looking at humans and Nile
ating themselves in nuclear war okay to
wrap up now if you're anything like me
when I travel around you go to airport
bookstores because you always forget to
take a book with you you go to airport
bookstores and they're full of these
books by political pundits telling us
what the future will be like America in
2050 the world in 2100 things like this
and I love these books I always buy them
I never learn my lesson which is I get
fifteen pages into them and get
infuriated and can't read any further
the problem I have with most of these
books is that the the picture you get in
them of the future is that the future is
basically like now it's like now but
it's faster it's like the Jetsons
yeah it's faster it's shinier China will
be a bit richer than the rest of us but
it's basically like now now that's the
one thing I think we can say is
definitely not going to happen the
future is not going to be like now
the 21st century is going to be a great
race between something like Kurzweil
singularity and some kind of catastrophe
that leaves all previous human
catastrophes in the shade I don't see
how we can possibly have a middle
outcome here any one of these two things
is on the cards and the slightly amusing
thing I'm using for me at least when I
was writing this book why the West rules
slightly amusing thing is either way it
turns out whether the east or the west
dominates the planet is simply going to
lose its meaning by the time the East
catches up with the West that's just no
longer going to be very important so
okay the great question for our times
and I would say is about not what I
wrote my book about not whether the West
will continue to rule it's a question I
came to at the end of the book
it's whether humanity as a whole is
going to break through to an entirely
new level of existence before disaster
strikes us down permanently so on that
cheery note I will stop and thank you
very much for listening
[Applause]
you know oddly enough we've had half the
people you quoted in this series of
Frank Fukuyama gave one more shot at the
end of history
Ray Kurzweil showed his graphs all going
toward the atmosphere stratosphere
there's the thing in your book which was
a geographical element that maybe this
is a good time to fill in which is what
happened to the impact of the steps and
the pneumatic civil empires and so on
when gunpowder became a big event you
want to just run that one down yeah yeah
I think that's a great question to raise
through through most of human history
the steps is a place where very few
people live at all because you it's
really hard to make a living there I
mean if you're a hunter hunter gatherer
I'm very difficult to make a living
there's just not enough to eat very
little wild human food available it's
not really until people start to
domesticated animals that you can make
the steps work for you at all cuz things
once you domesticate animals you can
then move on to the steps and we as
humans we can't eat the grass growing on
the steps but cows can and the cows eat
the grass we the cows so the steps begin
to become productive and then when you
start domesticating horses which
probably happened on the steps around
somewhere on 4000 BC when you do that
you begin initially the horse is just
like a fancy version of a cow and they
eating the horse it's a quite a long
time but eventually they get to the
point they figure out how to hook the
horse up to other things you begin to be
able to move around the steps become
much better than because you can move
from Oasis to Oasis support much larger
populations the Empire start to grow you
can by that point you can ride the
horses so you have lied down and raids
on these empires the steps begin to be
really a very wealthy part of the world
and this carries on they they go quite
suddenly between about a thousand and
500 BC they go for me in this backwater
so being an incredibly important part of
the world system and then even more
gruffly um between die I would say
you're really between the years 1500 and
1700 ad or C II they abruptly stopped
being a major part of the story and the
big reason for that is simply what you
mentioned the gunpowder and what happens
is um steppe nomads it seems pretty
clear the steppe nomads have a big part
in the initial creation of guns and
using guns and a steppe nomads of course
he could point a gun and fire it just as
well as anybody else
so which axis should say he or she I'm
stepping on our societies among the few
in world history where women have
regularly been warriors
so these step now my second points a gun
as well as anybody else but what they
can't is that they can't raise really
large numbers of men the way a settled
agrarian Empire camp and they can't pay
for them to train your round the way the
agrarian empires are beginning to be
able to do and they can't train them to
fire volleys in this sort of way they
can anomer can ride up a shoot and then
ride away again but the infantry from
the big empires they can say draw up six
ranks deep and the front rank can reload
its muskets and set them up on the
little stand and blast away and there's
no matters they ride around and they can
kneel down and start reloading so it
takes an eternity to reload these early
muskets second-ranked and blast away
then they kneel down and reload the
third-ranked and on you go and by the
time the last rank is fired front monks
ready to go again and up you stand and
you shoot again and this is so important
because like if if I had one of these 15
16th century our cabooses or muskets
right now I mean I can hit one of you
guys in the front row always a bad idea
to sit I could hit one of you guys in
the front row I could maybe hit somebody
in the middle but if I was told to hit
an individual in the back row there's no
way I could possibly do that but if we
got 500 oh it's all blast away at the
same time we can hit your everything
that's in front of us we'll get hit and
so when you 50 in like in the year 1500
nomads normally win their battles
against infantry musketeer armies by
1600 nomads sometimes win their battles
by 1700 nomads basically almost never
and as this happens the empires are able
to move on to the steps and shut them
down and once you stop nomads moving
around once you make it so they've got
to get your permission to move around
you basically killed the whole Nomad
thing and this changes the entire story
they they can't spread the disease and
the old so the way just everything
changes by 1700 because of the steps as
Europeans and East Asians open up the
oceans they simultaneously close the
steps this is what many changes you know
a version of your sequence the
difference between the Grand Canal being
the waterway that that tied together
China once they built it and the
Mediterranean which was there all the
time they didn't have to build it and
the Mediterranean being a similar Wilder
body of water than your average canal by
mastering the Mediterranean it seems
like the West was then the questions the
skills the technology all that stuff to
master Mediterranean they could master
the Atlantic and then they could master
the Pacific and in the Pacific War was
sort of the fighting out of East versus
West and who actually whose lake is it
and that was determined in four years
time this is pretty much of a maritime
story yeah maybe the oceans are
incredibly important in any any global
historical narrative and yeah because my
my whole shtick I kept saying is about
how geography changes its meanings as as
developments increases or or Falls and
so the oceans yo through history the
oceans have constantly been changing
their meanings and for a very long time
big bodies of water are obstacles more
than anything else LAN tick in the
Pacific are basically uncrossable and
this is one of the things that makes
global history so interesting is that
after modern humans move into the
America safe somewhere between twelve
and fifteen thousand BC somewhere in
that ballpark
um the Bering Strait land bridge
disappears and after that the oceans are
so big that it's only very occasionally
from then on the people cross over from
the old world to the new world and so
this makes this great
natural experiments you can look at how
new world civilizations developed and
how old world civilizations developed
they got to basically independent tracks
up to the points and the Spaniards go
over there and start slaughtering
everybody by breathing their bugs on
them
um and so yeah early on the oceans are
big barriers then gradually seas get
turned from barriers into highways so
initially of course the little seas
earlier like the Mediterranean Sea the
North Sea at the Sea of Japan and then
gradually bigger and bigger seas until
we get to the point now where people
people argue over this but some would
say yeah we're now reaching the point
where the oceans are basically starting
to become irrelevant to the story I
don't really think that's true I mean
you you look at the volume of God's ship
by container ships across the Pacific
oceans are still very very much with us
we still it's still possible for pilots
to shut down world trade I think this is
for historian this is just so cool I
mean I think you if you get kidnapped by
pirate this is not cool and people have
been kidnapped by this would really be
horrified that I can sit here and say
such callous things for his stories it's
really cool that pirates come back in
because this is exactly what a historian
what predicted the golden ages of piracy
or when you get a great up spike in in a
long-distance trade on the oceans
combined with weak states control of the
oceans and the problem we got now is we
yeah we could easily shut down these
pirates in the Malacca Straits or any
staff Raqqah but who's gonna do it
like who it has to be the u.s. really
but the u.s. is not gonna just walk in
and start shooting everybody again all
over the world and this is you know
Romans had the same problem the Chinese
had the same problem once the great
empires decide yeah we're gonna bite the
bullet and crack down pirates go out of
business but at the moment the Pirates
are not going out of business so the
next geographical scale and here's a
question from Brad in the long view how
do you see the geography of space travel
changing history the next geographical
scale is the planet as a whole which we
seem to be engaging in two modes one is
climate change at a global scale as a
global problem and also the prospect of
space travel yeah
yes
two things raised very I mean very
different sorts of problems and
challenges when I started writing my
book I viewed science fiction fan and so
I started writing the book I thought
yeah this is gonna be great and the
endless book talking about space travel
it'll be really cool and then I started
actually trying to learn something about
space travel and you know we all know
it's a long way to other stars we all
grasp this basic points but I think it
takes a bit of work to grasp just how
big these differences are and again I'm
sure there's lots of people in the room
know a lot more about astrophysics and I
do but the sort of the take-home message
I brought away with me is that unless
there's something about physics that we
are currently not grasping there is not
gonna be much in the way of really
fruitful interplanetary travel going on
but of course we're gonna be able to go
to the other planets in our solar system
and there may be all kinds of really
great stuff out there then we're able to
do they'll change the human story and I
mean I fall in the camp as I tend to
think any sensible person does it
thinking that there are a lot of
earth-like planets out there then you
know prior to 1995 we didn't know for
certain that any other planets existed
outside our solar system and now we know
if you know all these hundreds of them
and all the astronomers are saying yes
of course you're within the next few
years
we're going to identify earth-like
planets there's probably hundreds of
millions of them out in the universe so
you're in theory yeah we could hop
around to all these earth-like planets
it's gonna be great um but they're a
really long way away and so I suspect
unless there's something we don't get
about physics so this is simply never
going to happen the climate change so I
bad I think that simply is come down but
it's more scary is I'm a train to a
geographical issue and your spectrum of
considerations ya know and I have been
criticized by by thoughtless people
don't care enough about my feelings
criticized by people for being a little
bit loose when I talk about biology
sociology geography I am being fair
these are very loose and sloppy concepts
so you're where exactly climate change
fits into this nexus there the Sun is
room to argue about that I mean I would
see it very much
as a
force but one that can to some extent be
driven by what humans do as we're seeing
at the moment and one that of course
also it sort of ratchets up the pressure
on humans forces you to start thinking
about how you do things in new kinds of
ways and so um I I guess you're my guess
and where climate change is taking us is
that I'm you're like it or not there's
going to be some very substantial global
warming and particularly I mean I like
this phrase that I think is hunter
Lovins came up with originally that we
should talk about global weirding rather
than global warming that we're really
you know certainly we are looking at an
upward trend in temperature but we're
also looking at a huge increase in the
wildness of the climate and the amount
of rain you get in the big storms out
here in Northern California or the scale
of the droughts you'll get saying you're
further inland out in the southwest and
the the length of our fire seas and all
of these things are getting wilder and
weirder and I think you know this is
gonna happen we've got to just take this
one on the chin this is going to happen
there's stuff we can do about it
certainly but we don't seem to be scared
enough to do this stuff another one of
the the sayings I use throughout this
book history is driven by by people that
human beings are what as I said human
beings are frightened lazy and stupid I
think something along those lines and
this is what drives history's these
three things we've got to be frightened
of things to react to them properly I
think we started to get scared of
climate change and then we forgot about
it because very short term scary things
happened with the economy and we focus
on that instead I think you know
whatever we do now we're going to see
massive and melting of the polar ice cap
so going to see significant rise in the
sea level we're gonna see major change I
like to think that we are capable of
reacting to this climate change doesn't
have to be disastrous for humans but it
could be disastrous for humans if we
don't kind of pull ourselves together
reasonably quickly I think potentially
and it's not the kind of thing that the
world can heat up five or six or seven
degrees that's not gonna kill us this is
gonna change everything but it's not
gonna kill us what will kill us I think
is the way we react to climate change
and particularly there's this huge band
of the Society
these are the most vulnerable to climate
change and of arcing up through central
southern Africa to Central Asia out of
the East Asia where you've got most of
the world's poorest people most of the
most unstable governments in the world
the fastest nuclear proliferation is
going on in this region um the world's
water supplies are under the most
extreme pressure in this region I mean
it's just so depressing and when you
start thinking about then particularly
if you factor in that for the short term
at least the the most important energy
resources for the developed economies
the next 20 years are still going to be
the oil of the Middle East this is
terrifying
um if things were to get out of control
in the Middle East if there's a nuclear
showdown between Iran and Israel I don't
think it matters what administration is
in charge in the u.s. there is no way
the United States can stay out of a
nuclear confrontation between Iran and
Israel if the United States gets
involved I find it really hard to see
how Russia which is still the world's
biggest nuclear power if their nuclear
weapons actually work that's another
question but if they do they're still
the world's biggest nuclear power I find
it a little hard to see how they stay
out if the US gets involved in a nuclear
confrontation between Iran and Israel so
the how we react to climate change
that's what really worries me in the
short
oh there's another geographical angle I
know climate change you were describing
the great vulnerabilities to climate
being in the global south and as things
get warmer people move to higher
elevations and they move to higher
latitudes they move toward the poles and
the major difference geographically
between the south and the north is that
as you go toward the pole in the north
there's more land you're avoiding this
out and in North America why this out
but in the south as you go toward the
pole there's less land and so India and
Latin America and Africa all narrow down
in it to nothing and all you've got left
is Antarctica so presumably if people
are trying to leave the global south
because of climate change
they can't go south they'd have to go
north that sounds like a problem yes yes
this again with the the issues I was
talking about right at the end of these
Horsemen of the Apocalypse it always
seem to be involved in the great social
collapses you know a lot of people in
Europe and the u.s. get very bent out of
shape currently about immigration into
Western Europe and the u.s. from point
south I mean it seems to me that when
you look back at European and US history
across the last century or so on the
whole immigration has been a really good
thing for these economies and my feeling
is that the kind of immigration we're
dealing with at the moment it continues
to be in that category the scary kind of
immigration though is if we see um well
there's a British report came out five
years ago which predicted that we're
going to see 200 million of what are
called climate migrants out of this
global South area by the year 2050 200
million that is a lot of people if
you're getting tens of millions of
people migrating around Central Asia
South Asia it's getting very difficult
to see how the governments in these
regions are going to be able to cope
with these sorts of movements if you're
getting tens of millions of people
moving into Russia you might say in a
way that's that's good because Russian
population is collapsing so while
drinking themselves to death but um how
is this actually going to play out on
the ground I mean this is I think yeah
this is the terrifying prospect do we
have the level of institutions which are
basically created in the 19th century do
we have the institutions that can deal
with these kinds of global challenges
invention institutions can be a whole
subject but here's a question from
Dwayne O'Brien
how do you think the rise of
collaborative tools the last 20 years
will affect all of us the Internet
communications wiki smartphones so on is
that of a major player and all this in
terms of west-east and I suppose
quartiles rate of this and that or is it
just another bloody tool yeah I think
it's an interesting question really
interesting question if I mean yeah if
you think about the the great forces
have been transforming the world in the
last 50 years
um nearly all of our things that have
been happening in the West and I mean
obviously not all of them completely
South Korea is a robotic center that can
compete with almost anywhere in the
world but still you're on the whole um
these are things that are happening in
the West and I mean if you look at the
world today I think it's something 1/7
of the population of the world lives in
North America or Europe but something
like two thirds of the world's with
search and Development money is spent in
North America or Europe two-thirds of
the world's advanced weapons and
basically virtually all of its nuclear
weapons are in Europe or North America I
think all of its major aircraft carriers
are based in Europe or North America and
two-thirds of something else's or maybe
it's two-thirds of the patents but
overwhelmingly it's still the West is
the engine driving things forward and I
think you know the big question to put
on the table is does this mean that's
the Western domination particularly
there the technological end of things I
do tend to think is going to be the big
motor and the relatively short term for
what happens to us does the Western
domination at the moment of the
technology mean that in fact the West is
going to be able to kind of hold off and
fight off this great global shift or is
this just a kind of the tail end of the
older Western dominant said you're at
the moment it's a Microsoft or wherever
you might tend to who care to think
about the great corporations doing
things but 20 years from now it might be
Lenovo or Tata or one of these
corporations these are the big global
corporations and this I think this is a
very difficult question to answer
because you know they're the newspapers
and the weekly magazines are full of the
doom and gloom prognosis about the end
of American power and so on but um for
historian the really amusing thing about
these is how how closely they can be
paralleled if you look back in history
if you look back to the 1970s all these
people are writing off American power
you look back to the 1930s again all
these people are writing up American
power
America plunged into the Great
Depression in the 1930s in the 1940s it
turns around defeats the Nazis
overthrows Japan becomes the great
global power in the 1970s were plunged
into stagflation everybody's miserable
Jimmy Carter goes on TV wearing a
cardigan and everybody's appalled you
know world
and in the 1980s we overthrow the Soviet
you um so I think it's certainly not
beyond the belt the realm of possibility
then and then in the 2010s the US will
tap into another crisis you're probably
a fiscal crisis and then the 2020s will
bounce back to overcome all its rivals I
think that's certainly very possible
that um the Western powers will be able
to manage this process of change what I
think is much less likely is if we if
things don't change so much of the whole
question simply becomes irrelevant but
if we look at the question again 50 60
70 years down the line it's not gonna be
the West so I guess I tend to think
there's certainly that it's possible to
manage these processes it's not possible
for great men or great political
institutions though to stop them dead in
their tracks well it comes to a question
that Brad the earlier question raises if
you were to try to disprove your theory
or someone else were to try to disprove
your theory how would ya take to take
you down I think there's a lot of ways
that I could be wrong your pains me to
admit there are a lot of ways that I
could be wrong and I think you won and
what I'm doing here you know it revolves
around this Social Development Index so
the Social Development Index is one of
the ways I could be wrong in fact I
think this seems to me there's three
major ways that I could be wrong about
what I'm saying this index and one of
them is you could look at this index all
these numbers I'm banding around all the
time and you could say you know this is
just stupid that is the only word for
what you're doing it's stupid
you can't quantify human history in this
way you're just wasting your time
completely and then you could try to
show any a lot of people to think that I
mean I find their argument somewhat
baffling personally but a lot of people
do think this so you could try to make
that point you can make this argument a
second thing you could say okay I'm
gonna share this the basic concept
you're quantifying things comparing them
that's maybe not a bad idea but the way
you've got about the particular traits
that you've picked on the mechanisms you
use to score those are stupid and those
are the wrong things you're looking at
the wrong thing you're looking at
in the wrong way and I will show you now
what you should have looked at and then
of course I mean these arguments because
the only really matter if that then
leads you to a very different set of
conclusions at the end but that's
another place you can attack it third
way you can attack it it's to say yeah
the basic idea yeah that's good you
should measure things good idea um the
things that you're measuring yeah you
know the probably not ideal probably we
can measure something else certainly we
can measure it in different ways where
you show your stupidity they would say
to me is in what you actually do when
you come to be a historian and actually
look at the evidence this is where you
mess it up and just go all over the
place and go haywire and so um because
they're the good thing about these forms
of criticisms this is what I'm saying at
the beginning about that they're the
good thing about this approach is it
forces you to be explicit they may be as
wrong as is imaginable but even so I
will still feel pretty good about what I
did I mean not great not great but
pretty good because even if I'm
completely wrong and I would hope it's
move the debate forward by by forcing
people to be explicit and if they want
to show that I'm wrong about things they
then have to show why I and in the
process hopefully come up with a better
theory and you know it'll be hard for me
to admit their theory is better but
maybe I'll be able to do that and we'll
be able to say at the end of the day
yeah I was wrong but I move the debate
forward so yeah a whole array of things
and then of course the whole other set
you can say well okay maybe you're right
about all of that stuff but you still
interpret it wrong that having generated
all these scores um the the the story
that you tell goes wrong and then I
think I would be attacked in the
conventional sort of ways that a
historian would attack another historian
by showing that your new narrative that
you've constructed just doesn't connect
them well enough with the evidence and
so say they they might say like my story
I tell about the Scientific Revolution
how that is ultimately driven by the new
meaning of geography that's just really
stupid and I had lunch with a good
friend
on Monday who's a historian of science
and he was very nice about it and he was
kept saying oh yes of course you'll
write brilliant you're brilliant you
showed your if he's important that's
brilliant but you are completely wrong
about the Scientific Revolution that
that is not
by geography at all it that really is
driven by the ancient Greek stuff that
if the ancient Greeks had not had the
particular theories that they did have
about ellipses and the mathematics of
ellipses then Newton and Leibnitz would
not try to fill in the gaps between the
Greek thinkers they would not have
invented calculus and so um that I would
say is the fourth level in which the
theory can be attacked so you're
probably keeping score books has been
out for a year or so now and Neil
Ferguson thinks it's wonderful and
historian and Jared Diamond thinks it's
wonderful to collapse guy who else
thinks it's wonderful and who else
thinks you're dead wrong well okay my
relatives think it's wonderful yeah it's
been it's been a very interesting
experience the best reviews the book has
got have been in financial thing so I
got a great review in the economy it's
got a great review in the Financial
Times and to my surprise I've been
invited by a number of financial
industry based think tanks to come and
think talk about the ideas um the place
where I'm sort of guessing now
predicting the future guessing my worst
reviews I suspect are gonna come in the
professional historian journals and the
reason I'm guessing they're slow so they
haven't come out exactly yeah the
professional journals are bone achingly
slow um like within the in the popular
press if you review a book if you don't
publish the review within a month or two
of the book coming out there's no point
publishing because he needs to coincide
with the appearance of the new book
because that's why in the book it is
news briefly but in academia hey we're
in no hurry
we've all got tenure what do we care so
um we published very very slowly and it
generally takes one to two years for the
scholarly articles to come out and I
suspect that a lot of historians are not
going to like the book for some of the
reasons you talked about at the
beginning that it's trying to do things
that historians generally really really
don't like there's a period back in the
60s and 70s when historians started to
get quite excited about quantifying
things we then had this huge backlash
against it so quantifying things that
really bad that is going to upset people
I think but then you know launching off
to say yes having done this stuff about
the past we can now learn some lessons
to project them forward that's really
really bad and this is one of the
amusing things about my profession that
most of the academic profession why do
you think it's been is something bad
happen in the past that they're worried
about yeah partly that yeah partly you
look back to you guys like you mentioned
Karl Marx there's an example in a
slightly less of blood-soaked way I'm
saying of Toynbee writing in the all
these Browns theories of history yeah
it's a writer grand theory of history
you've got to do what historians um by
training and I think I'm likely refused
to do you you couldn't write a book like
this if every single statement that you
make is based on direct work in the
primary sources in the archives and this
is what historians do you you learn
medieval Chinese or whatever it might be
you learn the paleography you learn to
read this handwriting you go to the
archives you learn everything there is
to know about a tiny subject and you
come back me write a monograph about it
and that of course that is good if
people didn't do that we couldn't have
any serious history we'd still be you
know where we were back in the 16th
century as far as history goes the
problem I think is that historians have
said that not only is that good that is
so good that you shouldn't do anything
else and the costing of some of the
people who have done other things it has
been slightly embarrassing what they've
done but I think we really do have to do
the other stuff and one of the question
of why why do you have to do it well I
think this is kind of what history's for
almost everybody thinks this almost
everybody believes this and I think
history has our purpose meaning wow that
is big news I think you partly of course
we like history those of us who like
history do like it at least in part
because it's it's just interest and you
switch on the History Channel and you
know it's like 95% of the shows were
about Adolf Hitler but that's because
Hitler's interesting I mean who among
this has not sat slack Gorge for an hour
watching one of these ridiculous shows
about Hitler's interest in the occult
so whatever it might be it's just
infants just cool and meat but then I
also think that most of us do sort of
thing that history but you can learn
things from history and you can learn
stuff that tells you about why the world
is the way that it is at least a little
bit about why the future will turn out
in one way rather than another and you
know all the historians would like to
say you can't learn anything from the
past you cannot predict the future from
the past you're like when when George
Bush invaded Iraq in 2003 those
historians were not going around saying
boy I wish the Bush administration knew
less history because then they would
have foreseen the future they didn't say
that and this is I think is what makes
history such a lovable discipline but if
you go to the economics department say
and talk to these guys they will tell
you not only can we tell you all about
economics we can tell you about
everything else too and we wander over
to your biology departments they will
say yeah biology is the key to
everything and physics well shaaka
physics is also the key to everything
historians as far as I know historians
are the only academic profession whose
point of pride is that their subject is
the key to nothing and I find this
peculiar I find this that's a shift
we're gonna try to help move a blast
question take us back to archaeology
archaeology for you and archaeology in
the world is the long now foundation we
like looking at multiple millennia
archaeology you delve into that give us
a taste of what archaeology is meant to
you well yeah archaeology is just really
cool and I mean really is one field
archaeology is one of the most fun
things you can do if you like it if you
don't like it it is the most tedious
activity ever invented in the history of
the world
if you don't forget it if you don't get
the buzz of it it consists of moving
dirt from one place to another extremely
slow and this is because that is what it
is and of course you know if you do get
it then of course it's a hole yes you
are moving
extremely slowly yes you have to admit
that's true but there's a lot else going
on as well and it's just and it's just
really really neat feel sort of at the
academic level you're doing two things
at once and one of them it's kind of the
most focused and detail-oriented of the
human sciences because you can see you
say oh my take I was running in Sicily
for seven seasons um
one one area we spent seven years
excavating a single route across a
period that spanned about 150 years in
the past and I mean my god how nitpicky
can you get seven years in one rule
which 150 years are we talking about
this was from about 650 BC to 500 BC so
your very short period of time but on
the other hand you're also comparing
things across thousands of years and the
entire planet is a one of the
differences between archaeology and
being the text-based historian is that
um with text-based history the formation
processes of the evidence are very
culturally specific it's written in a
particular language you've got to learn
that languages all this very local stuff
about it
and there's so much of it to learn that
it becomes very difficult to study China
and then vault off to the Middle East
and learn Arabic well enough to do the
same thing whereas in archaeology you do
get some very specific formation
processes the climate and the geology
make a huge difference but it's only
kind of up to a point and so it's much
easier say for an archaeologist it's
very easy for an archaeologist to say
what I study is the Agricultural
Revolution and I study it wherever it
happens and whenever it happens and so I
know everything there is to know about
the origins of agriculture in the Middle
East but I also know most of what there
is to know about the origins of
agriculture in Pakistan and Mexico and
China and it's you've got to be really
really good to do that but there have
been such people where as historians
will tend to say I'm a historian of Ming
Dynasty China rather than saying I'm a
historian of civil wars and I am going
to study all civil wars whenever they
happen and I'm gonna pluck out the
examples of the most useful for testing
my theories historians very rarely do
that and there's a I think
good reason for that which is the nature
of the evidence but also there it
becomes this bad reason it stops you
from doing it but that's one of the
things that makes archaeology so cool is
these vast enormous comparisons and then
of course the digging part they're just
the physical experience of moving this
dirt that on the one hand it's just
extremely bad paid manual labor really
just painfully then on the other hand
it's a super high-tech activity and
you're uncovering the stuff I know you
you laying bare say the abandonment
deposit in the house it's burned down
around 500 BC nobody has seen this in
two and a half thousand years these are
the last moments of that house and
sometimes you'll catch um the the bodies
of the actual people who were there when
a building was destroyed caught in the
destruction one is a graduate student
they don't for quite a few years on a on
a project in Greece on the Greek islands
I'm directed by a Greek archeologist
whose wife is actually here tonight and
this is an amazing excavation I met my
own wife there and we excavated all
these bodies of the people caught in the
destruction around 1200 BC and it's
really hard not to like that stuff that
is just really great thank you thank you
all
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
you